another death sadly on our roads
yesterday a woman was hit and killed on
an electric mobility scooter hit and
killed by a car yeah and this all
happened near las vegas boulevard and
silverado ranch as kate houston shows us
neighbors there are really concerned
about what they say is a growing road
danger in that area
that's a very sad situation especially
because you think everybody would take a
little bit more notice especially to
somebody in a motorized wheelchair
it's just sad neighbors in the area of
las vegas boulevard and agate are
disturbed to see another deadly crash in
our little neighborhood it's very quiet
and we do walk around there with our dog
and stuff but we never come out this far
michael bates lives nearby and pointed
out a memorial across the street with
candles still lit those are for a
23-year-old motorcyclist who was killed
in a crash involving a pickup truck in
early october we've been in the area for
about five to six months and
it's sad to see something like this
happen again bates says there's a lot of
foot traffic in this area and drivers
should try to be more aware of their
surroundings from corner to corner
that's technically a crosswalk so
everybody needs to be mindful of it but
at the same time if you look at how dark
it is right through here and some of the
lights are out as memorials in the area
grow bates hopes something will be done
i hope they take the initiative and do
something especially all across las
vegas there's a lot of other areas not
just here but everywhere around here
they need to really step it up for the
pedestrians and for the people to watch
out for them kate houston live local now